in the previous trilogy you were always
talking to Jack's face now that you can
play this Jack well guess what you're
looking at
Jack's butt all the time and the problem
we had with Jack's butt is that it
really looked like a toilet seat like it
really looked like a toilet seat hey
everybody Rod Fergusson studio head of
the coalition and of course we make
gears v you don't know jack so why don't
you join me for the next few minutes and
let's talk about him we did gears for
because we wanted to show the coalition
could make a legitimate Gears of War
game but there was a feeling that maybe
we were too safe that we stayed too
close to the formula so the commander's
intent if you will the vision for Gears
5 was challenged expectations and that's
where you see the open-world side that
we did and then when you look at RPG
elements was something we wanted to add
and that's where our good friend Jack
comes in so Jack's been around since
2006 with Gears one you know we had high
you know big aspirations for Jack in the
first game to do a lot more than he
ended up doing that we were gonna take
control of them and beaten like actually
become jack and all those sorts of
things but we essentially had 18 months
to ship and things end up on the floor
so what Jack ultimately becomes is a
locking key system in the opening
cutscene you get to see Jack use the
kind of his trademark ability so let's
take a quick look at that
so there's Jack yay jack he's got these
sort of teardrop eyes because he's
supposed to be more expressive and it
allows you to sort of angle them and
give you a kind of an eyebrow II feel we
wanted him to be even more president Lee
in the Ultimate Edition that in the
actual first version here's one he kind
of just is there and goes away and we
felt like it was kind of under serving
Jack so when we remastered it we
actually show him their full in and then
we put a bunch of expression on him that
you'll see that when the helicopter goes
over he'll actually look up be afraid
and cloak and that was kind of Jack's
trick right like we didn't want him in
front of the camera and we didn't want
to mean in the way of shooting and it
was just you know was taking up
rendering polygons so basically we
cloaked him which meant when he went
away completely like that was one of the
differences between also Gears one in
Gears five and gears one when Jack
cloaks he's gone like he just doesn't
basically doesn't exist in Gears five
when he cloaks he's actually still there
and he has sort of his predator shimmer
and you can actually find him if you
want to again the sort of the
commander's intent for five was
challenged expectations and one of the
ways we wanted to really
that was to bring RPG elements in we
wanted to have special abilities that
you could level up as you played through
the game and initially we put them on
the character Kate could go and she
would you know essentially what looked
like magic right she would like put a
cloak on or she would summon you know
lightning to stun enemy then it it felt
kind of weird honestly like that was one
of the things we didn't really like is
that idea that as you're progressing the
character is changing so much and
getting special abilities that didn't
feel grounded when we thought about Kate
having this sort of magic lightning out
of her hand and you know force powers it
just didn't sit with us very well and we
thought hey why don't we put all these
abilities in Jack in that way we have
this robot the has abilities and we can
level them up and level up jack as we go
and so that Kate goes through a
transformation narrative Lee but she
doesn't actually become a different
person because if we think to the future
and we want to do another game now we
have to think about what does she become
from the previous game and now does she
have even bigger superpowers and all
this stuff where's if it's all contained
within Jack then it's all kind of
self-contained
and I think when we looked at Jack as
support we kind of had two inspirations
one was like you know Mario Galaxy the
other one was Elizabeth from bioshock
infinite that I worked on and that idea
that having the support character that
could be present and helpful but didn't
feel like it was taking away power or
control of the game and was super
important I thought Elizabeth was a
great example of that and so in some
ways Jack became our Elizabeth but along
the way we decided you know this is
really cool what if we make Jack a
playable character what if we were to go
from two-player co-op which is what
gears 4 was to three player co-op so as
a creator you're trying to take down
barriers and the biggest barrier for
anybody getting into a game basically is
the 60 bucks
so now game pass opens our world up
where we started with Jacqueline was to
say like let's not just focus on Jack
being playable
let's make Jack playable much like Mario
Galaxy was like oh I'm gonna help but
maybe I don't really know how to play
that much it was really just focused on
how do you bring a new player along back
in April 2017 we did an inclusive design
sprint at the studio it was part of
gaming for everyone that was at
Microsoft and we brought in four subject
matter experts and they told us their
stories about what it's like the game
with disabilities and it really
resonated within our studio like it was
transformative when you think about it
there's this inclusive design idea which
is you solve for one and then expand to
many and I think the best example of
that is subtitles it's
subtitles were invented for people who
are deaf or hard of hearing I'm willing
to bet that you look at subtitles at the
airport on the TV and you read subtitles
at the gym when on the treadmill so
that's not designed for you but you use
it and that was kind of the way we sort
of took that into has we thought about
accessibility within gears so we did a
lot around making our subtitle better
being able to control with one stick
getting rid of camera shake getting rid
of vibration if you know has options but
we really leaned in to Jack to also play
that role Jack has another entry point
for people like you know they have that
challenge but as we were doing it and
playing Jack Jack got really fun and we
felt like we were really close to
something super special around not just
having an easy way to play for either a
new player or a person with a disability
and so what we decided to do is not only
now that we'd started with
approachability for new players and
accessibility for disabled players we
were like what let's just focus on even
the hardcore and just make it really fun
we just kept iterating and iterating and
iterating and not losing the first two
principles but really focusing on how do
we make this fun and now like Jack is
hugely successful and then a lot of
people want to play as Jack just because
it's fun not because they're new or
what-have-you so we're really excited
about where that journey took us
so this is the line drawing for jak 4.0
at this point four gears five and he had
some interesting design challenges
because one of the things we wanted to
do was to make sure Jack look like Jack
and so what you see is these the
teardrop eyes here are a big part of
what makes Jack Jack and it also allowed
us to do some expressive things and
that's one of the things you know we
really wanted to do is not have a
toaster flying beside you we wanted to
have a companion we wanted to have a
squadmate and initially it got a little
pet like it got a little bit like here
boy here boy come here jack come here
jack can I go open the door jack and it
felt kind of demeaning and we wanted you
to care about Jack so we really tried to
play him up as an actual companion an
actual squadmate I mean the the values
of gears of war is found family but we
wanted to make it a little bit more like
he was part of the squad and not the
family dog propulsion was interesting as
you see with gears 4 and gears 5 we were
sort of taking it more believable I mean
one of the things to be like if you the
kind of squint at it I kind of think it
could be real so we went in with this
sort of single engine that allowed you
to have his propulsion for for Jack the
thing we weren't prepared for like when
you normally interface with Jack in the
previous trilogy you were faced on you
were always talking to Jack's face well
now that you can play as Jack well guess
what you're looking at
Jack's butt all the time and the problem
we had with Jack's butt is that it
really looked like a toilet seat like it
really looked like a toilet seat and so
that was one of the problems that we had
this notion of like we can't have this
flying toilet seat going around and just
just based on the shape that was here
like it was like oh it's the toilets
like it was and so we had to do a lot of
work to try to get that kind of hidden
this was important because we wanted to
be able to see the engine and see it
pivot and show off the cool visual
effects and give you a sense of where it
was going and it was responding to your
controls but again it it had a little
you know problem with the fact that it
looked like a toilet again being
grounded and believable we wanted to not
just have Jack pick up sort of science
abilities and just work we wanted it to
be visible on the character and see the
character change over time as you're
upgrading so as you upgrade his shock
ability maybe would show up there and we
like everything like basically there was
five or six different upgrades that you
could put on Jack that would show up
visibly in it and that really came to
life too in the in basically menu when
you go in
change the abilities you would see Jack
change over time as you're playing so it
felt like you were actually progressing
we didn't change him so much that he
became a completely different character
because again we wanted you to care
about Jack and we didn't want you to see
him as a flying toaster and we wanted
not to lose his face and lose his
emotion so we we didn't want to change
him too much we didn't want to transform
her him but we wanted you to feel like
oh he's getting stronger and more
powerful and and these attachments were
the way we did it once we made the
decision that all the abilities were
going to live in Jack it was about
finding out what abilities work best and
we had a bunch of different ideas but we
also had to think about how Jack worked
from an AI perspective what I loved
about Elizabeth and infinite is that she
felt very smart she was helpful she
would throw coins and ammo to you and
you never felt like oh you're so dumb
like you never had that moment what we
ended up doing is actually you see here
is basically jack is gonna go and make a
smart decision that says I'm not only
going to shock that one enemy I'm gonna
put down a shock circle that will encase
as many as possible cloak is a cool one
we thought was gonna be really useful to
change up the play style because you
know again from the original trilogy
Jack cloaks there's even a penny arcade
cartoon around like how come you have
this technology they can make an
invisible robot and I'm saying you're
getting shot all the time I've had it on
my wall up at epic the idea of allowing
the player to go invisible seem like a
kind of a no-brainer and introduce
stealth which is actually quite
challenging for us but that idea of
player initiated combat and letting the
player decide how to engage was really
important to us and so stealth kind of
fit into that you know Gears is known
for kick open door bullets start coming
even before you do anything get into
cover and kill them all and as part of
our challenge expectations we'd like
well now that the player has more tools
they can go invisible they can fetch
things there were so many more choices
we wanted to allow the player to take a
second take a breath and think about
what they want to do because it this is
the deepest gameplay that a Gears game
has ever had and so we wanted the player
to have the chance to think about it a
number of battles you'll go into the
space and you'll actually get to see the
swarm kind of just mingling about
because they don't know you're there yet
and that was a big change for us and and
part of that stealthy ability to cloak
and go all the way upstairs and take out
the sniper first it was part of that as
well let's look at a couple of the
abilities we ended up not using this
idea of dropping cover we wanted to
create this sort of idea of a temporary
force field if you will and we shouldn't
even played with the idea that it was
movable that you could actually lean
into it and start pushing it around as
you can see here it's
got really complicated and we use it a
little bit on the ice and so you know we
had we took that prototype and we
leveraged it in the level a few places
where you could push ice on ice kind of
things it just made the level design so
challenging to know that jacket would
cover anywhere that anytime you were
trying to make a challenge for the
player Jack had sort of override it
immediately by just allowing to drop
cover so it was just too game-changing
for us and that's why we got rid of it
we also went with like this idea that
you know Jack could be a fabricator you
know the sort of 3d printer in our world
we tried prototypes of Jack having the
ability of dropping turrets you could
get onto we had Jack drop decoys to
attract enemies to it but again instead
of being sort of the support where you
felt like it was helping you shoot and
it was kind of helping you in the
moment-to-moment gameplay it felt sort
of a fundamental difference and it also
made it sort of challenging around when
it gets to be player control but how you
cycling through all these things to
build and how do you tell Jack I want to
turret or I want a decoy and those sorts
of things actually
this is one of ones I want to wade just
kind of due to complexity - not only was
it sort of too game-changing but it was
also just complex example here is - is
this idea of like oh I'm going to call
in reinforcements so I'm gonna use Jack
to become to call in a guardian to help
me in getting AI bots to help you we we
kind of got around that with hijack and
so we liked the idea of oh I want to
take over an enemy as opposed to calling
in reinforcements and it made the play
interesting for Jack as I talked about
Jack wanting to be useful for people who
actually were high in players they could
actually if they wanted to shoot a gun
and be pixel person precise they could
hijack an enemy hijack a boss and become
that boss and then devastate the way
that you would in it as a normal player
if you didn't want to do just support
and so here's an example of calling in a
bot that you actually become that bot
when you call it in so now you've become
the guardian shield us up and you can
fly around and sort of destroy everyone
and this idea of that possessing a
helper possessing the enemy in a way was
really what sort of started off hijack
as an ability I mean one it's a killer
pot I mean come on hijack like this is
like people wanted to change the name
several times I would not allow it to
happen it had to be hijacked it was just
a cool ability to change the way you
play
we wanted him to be a squad mate and so
we were like what can we do around
personality and we played with a bunch
of stuff actually from full of
vocalization - no vocalization if you
think about Wally on one side which the
full kind of Wally you know like the and
being able to speak and then you look at
r2d2 which doesn't have any sort of
expressive ability other than kind of
the squeals and the beeps and the boobs
it was kind of this in the middle we
kind of wanted the facial and emotive
nosov Wally but we kind of wanted the
language of r2d2 and so we tried to
create this sort of like hybrid
character in that way because we wanted
to endear him to you because the things
that the journey the transformation
Jack's going to go through we wanted to
be important to you that you care about
Jack and not just like I might as a
piece of metal we do this little scene
here where Baird introduces them to the
squad and there's a couple things to
know we want to keep because as she says
at the start of act 2 I don't like bots
because I've been running from them my
entire life so she's not a big fan of
this whole tech thing so you go over and
then you know Baird is describing Jack
and his abilities and we use this moment
to let sort of Jack kind of like you
know be happy and show off his face and
kind of be expressive and you realize oh
there's something more here it's not
just a toaster right how's it going
through it you've been here Baird go
like this is what I do you and
ultimately you guys destroy it and so
then you see the odo what I'm gonna get
blown out like and so again showing off
some of the expression so there's this
kind of these cool moments where this is
sort of the grounding of oh there's more
to this than just a flying toaster
now we're getting towards the end so
spoiler alert if you haven't finished
Gears 5 stop now otherwise you're going
to ruin the ending for yourself so we've
been building up Jack now all the way
through we introduced him as a character
we made him part of the squad
you've been investing all the way
through basically every bit of
progression you're doing in the game
essentially he's going into Jack like we
felt like you've been investing into
Jack and we wanted there to be a cost of
war and like as a developer we kind of
want to hit the reset button too because
otherwise like you can expect Jack to
start the next thing with all of these
abilities you've upgraded and everything
and this allows us to kind of get rid of
that and so if we were to bring Jack
forward then you could have a fresh Jack
and start all over again
right so it's one of those things where
it's kind of like good for the story I'm
good for the design basically what we
wanted to as we were saying how do we
get to this point where we can have Jack
make his own decision and this was gonna
be a big moment as basically you're
fighting this giant monster you're going
to use these rail guns and you're gonna
learn pretty quickly like we can kind of
piss it off we can hurt it but we're not
going to win and so this entire game
you've been giving jack orders go do
that go do this open that door
give me that ammo cover me in clove
could give me some health so we wanted
this moment where Jack makes a decision
and Jack shuts down Baird and he decides
nope I'm gonna save the day I have the
beacon coordinates I can do this Jack
heroically sacrifices himself to save
the squad and the city and humanity and
so you have this really interesting
moment of this character that you've
been investing in throughout the entire
game and grown attached to and he does a
heroic sacrifice to save everybody else
and the number of people who have told
us and reacted to the fact that this
piece of metal with teardrop-shaped eyes
caused them to get teary eyed and
emotional and upset and yell at us and
swear at us because we killed someone
they truly liked liked and enjoyed
having their squad I meant a lot to us
and I felt like we accomplished our
goals with that so I mean when you look
at the journey now tears came out of
2006 so it's been 13 and a half years
like we go from this lock-and-key robot
that didn't really mean that much to
this squad other than baird and now
we've taken him 13 years later to this
place where he's a meaningful character
to the players who played either asked
him or with him and it was really
interesting to have that that journey to
go from this simple device to now this
sort of almost fully fleshed out
character that had abilities and meaning
and gameplay and in its own story arc
and on the journey and so when he looks
at you in the scene with his sad eyes
knowing he's going to have to make this
choice that Jack is choosing to destroy
himself in order to save everybody else
and so it was kind of a pivotal moment
and it helped us feel like a great sort
of arc of where Jack had started from to
where now Jack is ending and it meant a
lot to us he's a meaningful character
and everybody knows Jack when you think
about the squad in Marcus Tom and on
and Cole and Baird like Jack's part of
that and this felt like a really big
cherry on top of the sundae just you
know to sort of honor Jack as a
character in our game when I think about
when people come together they come for
the story we're given permission because
of the world we've built to have this
comic book sort of sensibilities we can
laugh at ourselves we can make really
bad jokes and and sort of have dark
humor we can have this sort of
blockbuster action movie sequences and
over-the-top set pieces and it's like a
summer blockbuster and then we can have
these sort of sweet moments sort of
sadness where whether it's the Morea
scene or the Dom scene or you know the
choice or or Jack the fact that we can
go from this sort of big men with thick
necks and all that stuff and we're able
to go now to where we're at a place and
play with that and make our storytelling
more contemporary and deal with grays
instead of black and whites where we can
have more complex characters and more
nuanced characters and yet we can still
bring out the emotion and and the fact
that people are responding that way to
the to the story is just so meaningful
to all of us and and we couldn't have
done it without you know obviously the
technical talents to be able to show
this stuff on screen but the voices the
cast that we have is amazing and Tom
Bissell's writing is amazing and it's
just been an amazing collaboration to be
able to tell this story and do it the
way we did
[Music]
you